okay London London all of us what are we
a [ __ ] octopus giving like
reach-arounds to to every fish on the
reef now all right relax branzino poor
no man it's fine it's fine it was a very
fun episode for me because I was working
with Becky Martin its director and we
were over in England a little bit and in
Scotland is quite a lot so yeah it was
an enjoyable episode to make although
there's some very very unfunny scenes in
it will you come with me as in down to
the boys family
I think we knew from early on we were
gonna do an episode where we wanted to
come back at the tragic events of the
end of the previous season but not in a
terribly direct way coming when we were
shooting at Jeremy can have its candle
so fully that it felt very heavy and
distressing to see him be there and look
at the minutiae I of a destroyed
family's lives do you think I should
maybe say some things of it I guess that
that's the terrible tragedy for Kendal
is that it's not a way for him to do
what he'd really like to do which is
accept some of the guilt that he feels
hey Tom one thing that's nice for us
through the season is you see what Greg
does when he starts earning bit more
money and he feels more comfortable in
his skin you played your head very well
I like it but we need to end this now or
I tell Morgan that you took copies of
sensitive documents their relationship
is in that weird area where it's
somewhat transactional they test each
other I to the limits of where they can
rely on each other how did it come to
this huh come on the disappearing sauce
sausage sausage Greg's got a decision to
make about where he jumps in the end
hey rare dad ray is here not a big deal
in terms of Logan and relationship we
liked seeing a different kind of
connection
yikes I can Kochi [ __ ] COO it's not
side to him that we've shown in the show
before he can turn on his charm and also
that he and himself can be charmed
on the kids who's caught it I could do
with a clear eye
why does Logan take to her parties that
feeling of light great this person can
sort everything out I think I might be
able to help you make this go away their
relationship is complicated but for the
kid is quite definitive danger sign
flashing there's a lot of different ways
that can fall away chiana plan I think
we got a problem
just be careful
you
you